elon is part of a select group of people
who can genuinely say that their
endeavors have significantly impacted
modern human life he has already changed
the automobile market with tesla he
plans to colonize mars with spacex and
he is on his way to cover the entire
earth with satellite internet using
starlink but now it seems like he is
also trying to disrupt the smartphone
market with tesla's new phone model pi
stick around as i discussed the
repercussion of elon and tesla entering
the smartphone market and the features
this new phone might have tesla model pi
features the rumors about the tesla
model pi started picking up steam after
the youtube channel adr studio uploaded
a video titled tesla model p concept in
february 2021. since then many netizens
have floated many theories about the
phone and try to imagine what it might
feature adr's video no doubt gave a very
slick look to the phone and showed us a
lot of its design language but it only
revealed a few basic features so let us
use that video as a guiding principle
and imagine all the features the tesla
model pi might pack construction
first of all the construction coming
from the tesla stables it is easy to
imagine that the model pi would be
constructed out of a high-grade aluminum
casing in fact adr's video indicates
that the phone's construction is strong
enough to withstand 150 megapascals of
force equivalent to 1500 times the
atmospheric pressure on the surface of
the earth this hints that the foam will
be constructed and designed to operate
under such extreme conditions now i'm
not saying that this means the model pi
can be used in space or on the surface
of mars but you can make of this feature
what you will because ordinary
smartphones are not usually constructed
to have such strong frames it will be
pointless for them to use a case so
unless elon and tesla have some specific
use case in mind for the model pi i
don't know what they would need to make
a phone that strong solar recharging
moving on to the back of the phone adr
studio imagines that the back case of
the tesla model pi will have solar
charging capacity i feel having a high
efficiency solar panel attached to the
back of a smartphone could be
game-changing not only will it make the
phone totally sustainable but it also
fits perfectly with tesla's value
proposition as an environmentally
friendly company plus a phone that can
automatically charge itself and become
totally free of external charging would
be a godsend for the modern smartphone
user portable solar panels have been
around for ages but they are usually
clunky and not very efficient this is
because most solar panels are made of
silicon and their density and surface
area define their efficiency
unfortunately converting silicon into a
dense photovoltaic solar cell capable of
converting light energy into electrical
energy and packing enough cells together
in a large enough surface area is a very
costly and ineffective process that's
why small chinese solar panels you can
buy from amazon generate a minimal
amount of power and they even need a lot
of time to do that suppose tesla has
somehow managed to crack the efficiency
problem with solar panels which i know
that they are currently working on in
that case there is no reason to doubt
that the model pi will ship with an
integrated solar panel on its back case
capable of charging its undoubtedly
colossal battery battery technology
speaking of battery size many people
have theorized that the model pi will
feature a massive 7100 milliamp hour
battery which is almost twice the
battery size of the iphone 13 pro model
suppose tesla was indeed planning to use
a solar panel to charge this massive
battery in that case it definitely needs
to make the battery more efficient than
all smartphones existing lithium-ion
batteries and what do you know they are
already working hard to create the next
generation of batteries for their
automobiles so they can easily
miniaturize that for a smartphone
tesla's new 4680 battery cell with a 46
millimeter diameter and 80 millimeter
length holds about five times the energy
of its current smaller 2170 cells and is
also easier to charge these lithium-ion
phosphate or lfp battery cells can be
used for the model pi with a few
modifications but the question needs to
be asked why does the model pie need
such a massive battery well this is
where the next few features of the phone
come in the cameras connectivity module
and the artificial intelligence aspect
of the model pi i could dedicate
different videos to each of these
features still for this video let's take
a quick look at how they make the model
pi so different from other phones
cameras and ai in adr's video the model
pi looks strikingly similar to the
iphone 12 pro max with a few key
differences first of all the camera
module is entirely different it houses
four cameras arranged in a square
similar to the galaxy s20 ultra although
a four camera setup is nothing new these
four cameras are a bit special first
they are tuned to excel at highly dark
astrophotography allowing users to
capture the night sky like never before
but more importantly the model pi's four
cameras are not just cameras they are
like an all-seeing eye designed to work
in conjunction with tesla's massive ai
neural net this is a neural net that
tesla is currently training for its
recently released fsd beta program it
will eventually take over the entire
tesla fleet a concept i have discussed
in great depth in my tesla's robo taxis
video anyways you might be wondering how
the model pi's camera system helps the
tesla ai well just like the tesla cars
have cameras and sensors to allow them
to see their environment think of these
four cameras as an extra set of eyes for
the ai so it will now use what the tesla
pi user sees through their camera which
these days is just about everything we
interact with in our daily lives and
it'll use that extra source of
information to perform various functions
around it for starters this will also
allow the model pi to be better
integrated with all tesla car models
allowing users to have more controls
through the tap of a button maybe users
can control features such as locking
unlocking temperature multimedia
navigation and even an ai show first
service which tesla has already claimed
to be working on with their robo taxi
announcement future smartphone users may
only need to sync their card to their
tesla phone and let the ai take care of
the rest this ai may also act as your
personal assistant based on your regular
interactions make suggestions optimize
your workflows automatically set
appointments for you recommend reading
and viewing materials based on your
preferences and give you health
recommendations and warnings based on
your eating and lifestyle habits i mean
the possibilities are really limitless
we are steadily moving closer to a world
depicted in the movie her where a
portable ai becomes people's everyday
companions now having a smartphone that
can do all that would be something
connectivity the next significant
feature that will be integral to making
all this possible and the ai viable for
the user of the model pi is connectivity
the model pi would be able to
communicate with the starlink network
when fully operational it would mean
that if you own a tesla model p you'll
have access to the internet anywhere on
this planet more than anything else i'm
really excited about this feature now
wouldn't that be nice for a phone that
can access information anywhere on the
planet without any connectivity hassle
gone will be the days of having to point
our smartphones to the skies to get that
extra bar of connection in areas with
spotty coverage now i can enjoy
high-speed internet everywhere of course
this feature will entirely depend on the
success of the starlink network still
with spacex already sending 2 300
satellites into orbit and launching a
successful beta program i am confident
about their goal of covering the entire
earth with wireless internet by 2030. is
the tesla phone real
there are various reasons why tesla
would like to enter the smartphone
market still i think that if elon were
to commit to this project it wouldn't be
unless it's a genuine generation
defining product like the iphone was 15
years ago anything short of that and the
model pi would just be another name in a
long list of smartphones released yearly
and elon definitely doesn't want that
the technologies required to develop a
phone with all the features described in
this video are just not there and even
though tesla is one of the most
cutting-edge companies they still don't
possess the technologies required to
deliver a product like the model pi
that's why the tesla model p is nothing
but a concept sadly there is no truth to
this rumor sorry to burst your bubble if
you thought we might get a tesla phone
soon but neither elon nor tesla have
ever hinted at a smartphone or that
there is indeed a project underway to
design such a phone however as a tech
junkie it is always fun to speculate and
suppose tesla is indeed secretly working
on a model pi smartphone concept and
announces it to the public at large in
that case i'd be the first person to
swallow my pride and welcome it with
open arms but until then there is no
reason to believe otherwise so what do
you think are elon and tesla working on
a smartphone project and if so what
features would you like to see in the
new phone let me know down in the
comment section below if you've enjoyed
this video subscribe to the channel and
give me a thumbs up i'll see you in the
next one